so I think that RoboCop's one of the
greatest movies of all time everything
about the film works well and it
balances brilliant satirical comedy
alongside its tragic story of a man made
into a machine throughout this video
we're going to be going through the
entire film scene by scene to talk about
all the cool details in it and also some
of the things that you might have missed
whilst watching it now there's so much
to love about the movie but originally
it wasn't actually an easy sell that was
primarily due to the film's name which
was seen as being extremely stupid look
it's a Robocop it's a robot cop it's
it's you get it straight away but
American directors were turning it down
left right and center and thus this
group was sent further afield to people
like Paul verhoven initially he hated it
too and The Story Goes that he read a
couple of pages of the script though it
was ridiculous and threw it away without
hitting the Thumbs Up Button however his
wife picked it up and read through it
and she managed to convince him there
was this gray comedic undertone that she
thought that he'd be perfect for and so
began with valving jumping on board the
project to make what I think is probably
his Masterpiece now we begin our journey
out in the far future and pick up in
Detroit during the year 2043 the city
has seen better days and we see it in
the midst of a financial and criminal
crisis everything has gone to hell and
this actually mirrors our own world and
unfortunately what happened with the
city the creative team correctly
predicted that Detroit would fall on
hard times and in the year 2013 the city
declared bankruptcy there's lots of
prophetic things throughout the film and
in order to understand how they managed
to predict this we have to look at the
way the world was when the movie was
getting made this was during a time in
which the Japanese had just started to
take over the car industry in America
machines were seen as being riddled with
issues if you even start typing on
Google why were American cars you're
gonna get an auto completing to say so
bad in the 80s deuterizing feel
emissions and safety standards
introduced at the time the automobile
industry in the US like behind a bit
leading to other countries dominating it
the heroven has a lot of fun with this
throughout the film and we of course
meet at 209 who has a number of let's
say issues designed by Phil tepid this
is the guy who built the 8080 and atsd
which you can definitely see Echoes of
here when crafting the machine tip it
pulled in elements of a killer whale and
also a Huey helicopter as that had its
own elements of satire to it the
designer wanted to create an allegory of
how the military-industrial complex
played into the Vietnam War and there's
very much this idea of combat for profit
in ocp's mission ozp is just the word
cop rearranged told you that'd be good
Easter eggs and they act as a way for
the creative team to comment on how they
envisioned a corporate control feature
you have to remember that this was
created during the height of the 80s
Wall Street movement and that was made
popular in movies like Wall Street that
was released the same year as Robocop
and it clearly commented on Corporate
America just as much as this did the
Hoven was basically imagining how bad
things were going to be in 60 years time
if they were already at this point with
Society in the 80s they of course also
pulled in several real world Illusions
in the characters too 2 the CEO of the
company is simply called The Old Man and
he's supposed to be a play on Ronald
Reagan the old man is kinda ignorant to
everything that's going on and he just
bounces about smiling and being Pleasant
during the time there was a lot of
attention on the Iran Contra Scandal
which involved the US going against the
arms embargo to secretly sell weapons
Reagan was pulling in question about
this and he acted aloof and just said he
didn't recall any of those meetings
I don't recall with these people I don't
recall a few months ago I told the
American people I did not trade arms for
hostages
my heart and my best intentions still
tell me that's true but the facts and
the evidence tell me it is not I'd say
if you want to see it or there if you
don't and I think RoboCop's greatest
strength is that it works on these
satirical levels whilst also being just
a solid movie now a really cool line in
the film gives away that ocp were
putting policemen in dangerous positions
so that the corporation could quickly
get their hands on a candidate when we
meet Murphy we discover that he's just
transferred in and this is because he's
someone who'd be perfect to undergo the
experiment a throwaway line we hear Bob
Morton say we've restructured the police
department and placed Prime candidates
according to risk factor I'm confident
that we can go to prototype within 90
days and these shows that he's been
using his power to restructure the
police so that one of the ideal officers
will get killed and then they'll be able
to use him this is also touched upon in
the opening news report when we get this
section three dead police officers one
critically injured police union leaders
blame Omni consumer products ocp The
Firm which recently entered into a
contract with the city to fund and run
the Detroit Metropolitan Police
Department it shows just how cold and
heartless that the corporation is and we
get this idlas throughout all of the
figures in the boardroom one of the guys
Bob goes up with in the lift is the same
person who gets killed by at 209 but
instead of being shocked Assad he just
sees opportunity pitching his idea
allows him to take attention away from
dick Jones who becomes another one of
the film's big characters we learn later
on that he's been working with the
villain Clarence bottica showing how
he's managed to manipulate the situation
to his Advantage too we learned that the
police force has been privatized so that
ocp own it and in order to make more
money the crime rate has to be higher
thus by funding the criminals this is
causing more chaos meaning more drastic
measures have to be put in place they
are also looking to replace the police
as well and rather than having officers
that can quit and go on strike they want
robots on the job instead really the
movie also predicted a lot of fears
around AI with us even getting police at
the shooting range saying this guy is
really good he's not a guy he's a
machine what are they gonna do replace
us
we even get a line about how robot cops
in on GD 24 hours a day officer that
doesn't Tire asleep this was actually
based on The Day the Earth Stood Still
with a robot gourd also being described
as this now what I love about the film
is that the two villains in the piece
both represent the two sides of crime
that can exist in our world we have the
sleazy street level crime encapsulate
and body care and then the elite white
collar crime embodied in Jones really
shows how efficient that RoboCop is at
tackling it and it allows him to be a
hero that rights the wrongs in both
areas now Peter Weller originally wasn't
supposed to be the character and instead
they wanted someone like Michael
Ironside in the role however they
realized he was too big to fit in the
suit and thus they ended up looking for
a Slimmer actor to become the man in the
machine another stipulation was that
they had to have a strong jawline as
most of the time we'd only see the
actor's mouth well that definitely
brings that and in preparation for the
role he took on mime lessons in order to
learn how to move like a machine however
upon getting to the set he's saw the
suit was way bulkier than what he
practicing and most of his moves ended
up being useless he had to relearn
everything using the suit but that
didn't make things easier because of how
bulky it was there was a ton of issues
when filming and this plagued numerous
scenes whenever robo cops riding around
in the car well that doesn't actually
have any pants on and this is because
they were too big to fit in it during
the moment where RoboCop catches the
keys at the police department they also
kept bouncing off the gloves thus they
had to film this 50 times until well I
managed to grab them however I think
that this suit looks incredible and that
iconic poster it just sells the movie I
love the way that the light bounces off
it and you sometimes get a purple gleam
amongst the blue that really makes it
stand out now the seat itself was
designed with a production team looking
at comic book characters Judge Dredd was
seen as the basis and we also get two
other ones who appear in the movie when
the mugger is going into the convenience
store he passes by a comic book stand
and he picks up a copy of none other
than Iron Man this is of course about a
man who makes a robotic suit for himself
and next to it also an issue of ROM the
space Knight now we begin with the Orion
logo which instantly takes you back in
time there's actually a really funny
joke in RoboCop 2 and we get a moment
where a list of texts appears on screen
with avoid Orion meetings right in the
middle of it this is because the studio
were notorious for demanding rewrites
which the second film had to heavily
undergo anyway from here we could have
the skyline of what's supposed to be
Detroit but this is actually Dallas but
Harvin just loved the skyline of it and
he decided to head there instead due to
being able to superimpose things because
of how flat the city is huge in ads
they're now playing podcasts for talking
about the history of Dallas and they
said that Architects loved the build
there because there's no mountains or
structures that draw the eye away from
their work anyway from here we get to
some news reports and commercials
highlighting several products that
either show up later on or ones that
have payoffs in the upcoming reports
during the 80s we saw saw a major change
in how the news was reported and both
CNN and fox were networks that were
launched during the decade whereas in
the past the news had been centered
solely on delivering information here it
switched to delivering entertainment the
now playing podcast also pointed out
that one of the reporters's
entertainment tonight's Lisa Gibbons who
was nicknamed sleazer at the time known
for her tabloid journalism and let's say
lesson reputable reputation the tagline
that the news uses instantly sets a tone
for what's going on this is Media break
you give us three minutes and we'll give
you the world
obviously you know this isn't going to
be a deep look on the world and instead
it's just going to be the headline and
attention grabbing statements that tell
a fraction of the story it sent me a
journalist now regularly use on the
internet and a lot of time people just
read their headline and don't actually
get into the story like what we have
here now in one of the reports we learn
about the Star Wars satellite
malfunctioning in space which caused the
visiting president to experience some
weightlessness due to the lack of
gravity later on we also learn that
there's a peaceful platform that we find
out malfunction and shut out some lasers
that actually killed three retired
presidents back on Earth who cares if it
worked or not we even find out in the
boardroom that ocp Dublin space
exploration which could hinder them
being behind these two things hospitals
prisons space exploration
I say good business
is where you find it now the house
themselves also smile away as they
deliver what should be devastating news
showing how sanitized they want to keep
the entire thing now the use of
commercials and of the top goal was
actually used for a specific reason and
verhoven was making Digs at how much
people relish violence especially when
it comes to the cinema the take pointed
out that RoboCop himself is supposed to
be a reaction to the pistol-packing
heroes such as Clint Eastwood and
Charles Bronson when RoboCop saves the
store owners he probably causes more
damages than what was in the safe but
everyone so caught up in enjoying the
action that we simply don't care things
get more and more extreme the more the
movie goes on and it also works as a
parody of what movies are devolved into
during the 80s which is elevated by how
stupid the name is RoboCop it's
basically what chat GPT would come up
with if you typed in write the script
for an 80s movie but it's well aware of
what it is and that's why it works so
well and there are actually two versions
of the film of available and originally
the movie had to be submitted to the
MPAA over 12 times they forced them to
cut out several of the violent ports and
eventually this got a cut down from an
x-raying to an R the main things that
had to go were things like how long had
209 blasted the guy for and some of the
more graphic and gory sections we get
now you're gonna be hard-pressed to find
that theatrical cut these days and and
verhoven's fully behind the more Goring
graphic director's cut I picked up the
release from Arrow for this video and
whereas with the Alien movies you got
both here it's just the one I can't
really show any of these scenes because
YouTube keeps demonetizing the channel
whenever we show blood but when
re-watching them bother I think the
director's cut works way better because
it prolongs the violence the satire here
is that it's meant to go on forever and
be so over the top that it just shows
what audiences want from a movie like
this when it's go down it actually feels
more violent because they don't get to
drag it out at the point of being funny
so yeah to me having a longer version
works way better and it's easy to see
why that's the one that's stayed in
circulation anyway from here we go to
the police station and instantly get
just how tongue-in-cheek some of the
dialogue's gonna be
I take this murder it's not like he
killed someone anyway we see Murphy
introducing himself as a transferring
officer and he watches a dead man's
Locker is cleared out signifying how
dangerous the job is the harman wanted
to have a Cohen Locker situation here
where both genders got changed in the
same place and this is what he Invasion
the future is being there are little
nods to it but they go by so fast that
you'd not really pick up on them and we
actually get something like this later
on in the director's career during
Starship Troopers in that we have both
men and women showering together which
he inserted to build off the back of
this scene anyway the police Strikers
also mentioned too which becomes a big
thing later on privatization by ocp has
left the department on the back burner
and we've often seen things like this
happening with companies in the real
world just a couple of weeks ago
transpennine had to be brought back
under government control and this kind
of thing highlights the way these deals
tend to work a national service goes
private and then when the profits dry up
they call in the government to help come
pick up the pieces it's a sweet gig for
those up at the top and we see just how
cold and careless at those in the
corporate offices are to them it's just
about business and money and they don't
really care that people are losing their
lives now we often hear of insurance
horror stories where people are denied
life-saving claims because someone
somewhere signs it off without actually
looking into the case people can detach
themselves from things they don't have
to deal with personally and I think it's
smart to show both sides of this in the
film now from here we're introduced to
Nancy Allen's officer Anne Lewis the
creative team purposely tried to make
her as masculine as possible because
they didn't want the stereotypical Kind
of Love Story attached to this film
later on we get a nod to this when she
nurses RoboCop back to help after he's
put through the ringer and left a dead
store we see him shooting at cans of
baby food and on the director's
commentary they talked about why this
was picked they said they wanted to
completely eliminate the possibility of
them hooking up so robocopier is
literally shooting the baby now
originally Stephanie zimbless was
supposed to play Lewis but she was
contractually obliged to film five
episodes of Remington Steele and thus
Nancy was cast in the role instead it's
a similar sort of thing to what happened
with Tom Selleck who was supposed to
play Indiana Jones but we all know how
that turned out and it was probably it
was for the better let's be honest now
Beethoven apparently thought Alan looked
too feminine and thus he kept making her
go and get a haircut shorter and shorter
until it appears like how we see here
Alan two went with the idea of being as
desexualized as possible and she
apparently even woman's underwear to get
into the role anyway after the board
scene plays out we see Murphy twirling
his gun he says uh yeah well my son
Jimmy watched this cop show TJ laser and
this laser guy does this every time he
takes down a bad guy so naturally my my
kid thinks I have a good cop should be
and you don't want to disappoint him
yeah well this is the play on the cop
show TJ hooker which is about a
detective who demotes himself to tackle
crime on a street level that kinda
glamorized at life too but we see with
Murphy how dangerous it can be with
Clarence buttercare you watch him and
his gang coming off the back of rubbing
a bank and Clarence instantly let us
know how threatening he is he tosses one
of his own men out the back of the van
and I kinda saw the parallels here with
the Cobra people who were willing to
throw each other under the bus just to
get ahead and normally the Instinct with
a character like this would be to go
with a big bulking henchman but barika
breaks the mold this is because verhoven
had witnessed elements of the Holocaust
first hand and he thought that when
kurtwood Smith wore glasses that he
resembled Heinrich Himmler Smith wanted
to be the villain that seemed like he
couldn't be outsmarted and therefore
they added glasses to make him appear
more intelligent he definitely comes
across that way too and watching him
brutally murder Murphy Hammer's home
just how much of a bad guy is now inside
we see some of the gang watching TV and
this spawned the infamous catchphrase
this is actually a play on the 1950s
sci-fi Story the marching which
said I'd buy that for a quarter it's
been adjusted for inflation and it kind
of speaks to the moronic comedy garbage
that people lap up in their masses much
like how they do violence but um I must
be a as well because I quite enjoy
that stuff shoot him some more
now Murphy eventually gets caught
leading to his torturous death scene at
the hands of body care I'm not sure how
much of the death scene we can get away
with showing but it's sort of like the
crucifixion with Murphy being spread out
on a christ-like pose and getting a
metaphorical nail through the hand later
on we will watch Robocop walk on water
and he of course goes through his own
Resurrection now we see further
parallels between the low-level
criminals and the white collar ones as
Bob Morton says that they should just
cut off his other arm because it's not
going to be of an ease to them
lose the arm well don't really care and
they're happy to mutilate someone just
to get what they want are there Clarence
doing this in some way brings about his
own end as the honey blows office the
same one that RoboCop uses to stab him
had he not blown this off then they
might not have removed the other one and
I'll fit them with these little gadgets
that RoboCop uses as a weapon really
nice way to bring it all full circle
with bodako also standing over him again
with Murphy at his Mercy a movie shot
through the back of the head and we
watch as the camera goes from his face
to the other side so we can see this pop
out this was achieved through using a
dummy which we can see in the second we
get before it turns around and from here
Murphy's rushed to the ER where we see a
medical team dealing with him he's on
actors and they're having got the group
in turn the cameras on and said act how
you'd act if someone like this came in
it adds such a feeling of authenticity
to it and we see Murphy's life flashing
before his eyes as he passes away in the
Visions he sees the TJ laser clip with
TJ himself somewhat resembling rubber
cop due to the helmet and black visor
even his death has this idea of coldness
to it as rather than him getting an
impactful goodbye with his family we
just here all right I think that's all
we can do let's call it what's the time
I think it shows out when you're dealing
with people in professional positions
how everything can kind of just turn
into being a job and it continues the
idea of how little life means in this
world not slagging off doctors and
nurses yeah before you start but I think
this film is trying to show how detached
everyone can become now from here we cut
a rubber cops prv which uses real-life
Ms Stars coding to show the system
according to Reddit when he's first beat
it up we get hexadecimal numbers along
the bottom which when translated with
ASCII spell Ed Solomon a producer on the
film we get the idea of time passing due
to them celebrating and it also draws
out the reveals so we don't see what he
looks like except for on the poster and
in the trail out that everyone watched
beforehand but you know what I mean it
drags out that reveal now back in the
police station we get another great line
I am what you call a repeated Fender I
repeat I will
also I think that we get a cup in the
bottom right looking over criminal
profiles with us ending on bodica bit
difficult to make out but this could
tease that the guy is still at large
either way the revealer RoboCop is
dragged out further and I love the way
they use those bass booms to Signal his
footsteps coming in we watch him
blasting away his gun and originally
they wanted to use it as an eagle which
Wella even practiced with however upon
putting it in the suit they realized
that it was far too small for the gloves
and thus they added stuff to a Beretta
automatic pistol in order to dress it up
a bit rubber cop heads out and we get
Morton saying yeah go get him boy again
this ties into the idea that he's very
much a lap dog for Morton that's under
his control and from here we go to the
right scene in which RoboCop saves a
woman originally they were gonna shoot
past the victim's cheek but verhoven had
the idea to shoot the guy in the junk
whereas normally the scene would have a
heroic shot of the Damsel in Distress
thanking the hero with a kiss we see
just how I'm feeling RoboCop is and it
adds an undercurrent of humor to this
horrific event Madam you have suffered
an emotional shock I will notify a Rape
Crisis Center
clearly this guy is in a classic
charismatic hero and instead he's just a
stone cold robot that feels absolutely
nothing anyway from here we go to the
hostage scene which is based on a real
life event X San Francisco's supervisor
Dan White wanted his old job back and he
ended up killing supervisor Harvey Milk
and mayor George modscone this was
documented in the movie milk and it also
led to the legal term Twinkie defense
being coined this and I'm not sure yeah
this would be because white yeah he
argued that he had diminished capacity
and that he should be charged with
manslaughter because he was suffering
from depression due to switching his die
to Twinkies we see a little nut of this
in the scene but the characters eating a
Baby Ruth bar instead of the sugary
snack I'm pretty sure the police offered
to give the guy one of the cars we see
advertised throughout the movie and we
also get some clear parallels to The
Dark Knight Returns rubber cop burst
through the wall to grab the guy and
this is similar to how Batman did it in
that book Frank Miller created that
comic and he was actually brought on to
help write RoboCop too stuff was changed
hence the Orion reshoots comment but
Frank Miller's robot cop can be found in
comic form if you want to check that out
weirdly Peter Weller would like to go
and devise Batman in The Dark Knight
Returns animated movie which too
features the hostage situation and the
book itself is also filled with news
reports and this movie adopts a similar
framing device in order to tell its
story Aruba cops able to grab him
through the walls because he has
infrared vision back in the day yeah
this wasn't exactly something you could
buy over the counter and the Hoban
realized he did up a lot of the film's
budget just to buy a camera with an
infrared spectrometer thus they did
things on the cheap and instead just
used fluorescent body paint on the
actors and filmed it using a black light
you'd not be able to tell though unless
of course you knew that and it works so
well to show us what RoboCop can do now
next we see RoboCop being introduced to
kids at school on a report where the
reporters chuckling away at him telling
the kids to stay out of trouble when
making the movie now playing said that
because verhoven had witnessed the rise
of Nazism first hand that he wanted to
lay fear of fascism is an undertone to
the film however he called it liberal
fascism and stated that though they were
aiming to achieve a Utopia they'd have
to do it through creating a police state
that has excessive force use throughout
it's such small commentary and we then
cut to two ads in between the reports
the first of these is Nukem which is
basically Battleship but with nukes
instead during the 80s there was a lot
of fear surrounding nukes but this is
trying to take that and commercialize it
to make it fun for the family you can
also appears in Back to the Future too
with it being a nice little in-joke
about what the future could hold in
store for us and we watch as Morton
makes his way to the top and even gets
access to the executive toilet this is
seen as being the height of luxury and
it's where dick Jones and his rivalry
starts to really begin Morton was
supposed to be arrogant and unlikable
however I think everyone would probably
admit to liking Miguel ferreira's
performance as him realizing this would
likely be the case verhoven did rewrite
elements of the script to make him seem
more pleasant but he still definitely
doing a lot of shady stuff and some
really good lines here again I used to
call the old man funny names
Iron Butt boner once I even called him
but there was always respect
yeah I don't know if there was respect
there mate now if you respect the work
that went into this video then please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every week you wanna support the
channel you can also check out our merch
store Linked In the description below
which has a range of heavy spoilers
t-shirts hats and a lot more
I like it anyway at this point RoboCop
starts to have flashbacks of his past
life and this is made worse by Smith
recognizing him and telling him his name
could do a meal out and about and we see
him toying with a gas station Clerk
I bet you think you're pretty smart huh
I think you get out
how smart for himself as he wore glasses
and studied maths and one day adorning
him that someone could just shoot him
and that all that's studying would mean
nothing it happened to say by RoboCop
though who says
Dead or Alive you are coming with me
Dead or Alive you're coming with me
foreign
[Music]
and this of course calls back to the
line earlier but it's also meant to be a
nod to the sheriffs of the Wild West
who'd say the same thing again this
leads to a gigantic explosion and a meal
crashing into a car which leans in with
the idea that he's destroying more
property than he's managing to save
tracking bodica through a meal he then
recognizes from the memory flashes that
he had in the chair coming face to face
with himself he attempts to go home but
he finds it abandoned and now on sale
now originally they had a different
scene planned out for this and he'd
arrived there to find his son wife and
his old dog this was supposed to be
similar to The Odyssey where Odysseus
returns home and no one other than his
dog recognizes who he is that would be
the case here too but verhoven decided
it was too sentimental so it was
scrapped however they did end up
bringing something similar across in
RoboCop 2 where he passes by and his
wife recognizes him the scene was
somewhat also adapted for the 2014
RoboCop remake when he had something
along those lines when he returned back
to his home anyway from here we go to
the club and and get a little Cameo by
Paul verhoven he was trying to show the
extras how he wanted them to dance and
did a manic little jig which they then
left in the film now from here we jumped
to Bob Morton with two ladies verhalvin
actually referred to all the actors by
their character names and apparently he
dressed these actresses by their name
which okay moving on now
butterka arrives as a messenger of death
it shows just how ruthless Jones is and
Morton is killed so that he can make a
power play anyway we could do a drug
Factory and see further similarities
between baracker and Jones as they both
say this think about it John good
business is where you find it I say good
business
is where you find it the deal is bussed
up by Robert Cobb and we get a nice
little detail here that happens in a
blink and you'll miss it moment when
borica is at the top of the stairs
RoboCop has the same on him but he
shifts us to the side in order to shoot
men instead Rubble cop had him dead to
rights but he changed the Target because
he wanted to deal with Body Care on a
hand-to-hand basis now another nice
detail happens when RoboCop doesn't
actually start recording until he reads
him his Miranda rights he throws him
through the glass throughout the scene
but he doesn't actually hit record until
after he's finished reading everything
in the end he wants to kill him but his
prime directives hold him back which
would teased that earlier in the movie
these laws are actually and no to the
three laws of robotics which are dreamed
by science fiction author Isaac Asimov
in the short story run around it's easy
I'd save dick Jones and he of course
knows that the secret Port directive
protects people like him he so lacks
about RoboCop arriving that Jones even
Taps his fingers this actually nicely
lines up with the film's score
thank God
[Music]
Jones is above the law and this is
clearly a common in corporations in how
ownership leads to control if the police
are privatized then the law itself can
be controlled leading to him unleashing
Ed 209 such a good scene and you can see
the rocket traveling along a little line
to keep it on course but a movie Magic
that anyway it falls down the stairs and
tip it achieved this by well just
pushing a model down the stairs now they
also integrated Pig squeals into the
screams and we get the idea that it's
like a little chicken rolling around
[Music]
it shows just how useless that the
machines actually are if they can't
tackle stairs unless humans are relied
on to take RoboCop down though the
police try and help out it's the SWAT
team that does it and you might
recognize their leader as being the guy
who worked in the hostage situation
before anyway RoboCop has left at
death's door and Lewis comes in to save
the day from here we get the news report
announcing the strike in Lynn Jones's
plans for Delta City all the residents
will be people he and bodaka can sell
Vice to allowing them to go on and make
more money we then see the iconic scene
in which Murphy removes his helmet and
he finally shows off his face it's such
an incredible effect with them using
Prosthetics on the side so it seems like
his skins pulled over the helmet they
did a similar thing with a high
evolutionary and it adds the idea
there's a man in there or at least the
illusion of one now he sees the city
descends into chaos and watches the bad
guys get their hands in a 6000 sucks
which was shown in the advert they also
mentioned about how Clarence has this
car
still got the
got the dick around it Clarence Joey's
got a car just like yours man another
one we see here gets blown up another
FPS at the factory because it belonged
to Clarence anyway heading out to the
abandoned Factory we get the final
confrontation and the toxic way scene
that I think stands out as one of the
most memorable moments in the movie The
npaa we're actually going to cut this
scene because they thought it was too
graphic but in test screenings they
scored the highest so they left it in
toxic waste was such a big thing in the
80s as well they're constantly being
reported corporations had been dumping
it so I think it's playing on that and
the location itself also has deeper ties
too on the commentary the creative team
said that they chose the Rust Belt
setting to tie back in with the whole
automobile parallels we talked about and
RoboCop is also kind of going back to
basics The Showdown happens with borica
surrendering criminals prey on the law
and its rules and he knows that he can
just be taken in and then freed again
how about RoboCop isn't there to arrest
him which causes us to seem afraid for
the first time however bodica gets the
upper hand and he has him at his Mercy
once more he Stakes him through the
heart almost like he's some kind of
Undead vampire Murphy kills barika
though and he then says they'll fix you
they fixed everything feels sort of
ironic and uh tongue-in-cheek thing as
well especially after all Murphy has
gone through making this one of the
movie's most memorable lines now from
here we go to Dick Jones giving another
boardroom speech and watch his RoboCop
destroys the Ed 209 on the driveway I
love how we get this tease of its legs
coming in like it's still on the hunt
but then it wanders further into the
frame to show that it's now gone
appearing in the boardroom echoing the
arrival of Ed 2009 before we watch his
RoboCop reveals the truth about dick he
goes just like the mayor did before but
upon being freed Murphy is able to act
dick falls out the window and yeah we
know it's a dummy but it's all right Die
Hard would of course do this shot way
better the air after but it says goodbye
to dick and he goes off when he's Jones
another interesting parallel that shows
the corporate industry level thing is
how both Jones and Buttercup are brought
down by the USB thing in his hand but
it's done in different ways the footage
is shown on TV through it and it's of
course also what RoboCop used to stab
barika with the street level stuff is
taken down with violence whereas the
corporate side is taking down
electronically which also mimics how
these two sides of crime are often
carried out now in the end the old man
asks RoboCop his name and he says
Murphy
now that's the perfect way to end the
movie and it's showing that he's now
getting back in touch with his Humanity
I love the little charming smile too and
it gives the idea that the once metallic
man is close to being the person he once
was what about the Easter eggs don't end
there and at the end we get a little
joke and the copyright disclaimer it
says this motion picture is protected
under the laws of the United States and
other countries and it's an authorized
duplication distribution or exhibition
may result in civil liabilities and
criminal prosecution by enforcement
droids so yeah I mean I like that and
all in all I'd say RoboCop is I'm gonna
say it it's the perfect movie can't
think of any way that it could have
improved or bettered this as the script
super tight and the satire still works
well today it's easy to see why we've
had things like the shot for shot remake
created and the fan communities kept
coming back to this film for a reason
it's a brilliant piece of work I already
feel like watching it again and I hope
that you've enjoyed going back to it
with us I am trying to release these
breakdowns early for members on the
channel so if you want to watch them
before anyone else you can support us
for as little as 99 cents a month and
see these as soon as we have them ready
go to males to watch then make sure you
check out our video on Alien 3 in which
we go through the initial drafts the
director's cut differences and all
Easter eggs that we could find in it
huge thank you for all your support and
hopefully I'll see you on our next one
where we're gonna be tackling the
Terminator I'll be back for that and
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been Paul you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace